i talk um
um all the time about how fortunate i am
to be the the host of nfl network from
its inception and i mean every word of
it in 2003 is when we came on the air
and the number of people that i've
gotten i mean it's just the journey it's
about journeys and and stories and um
and distance traveled michael irvin
always likes telling stories like that
and the number of of uh men and women
that i've gotten to meet through my job
um and their love of the nfl it just
comes through and it's a
something i don't take for granted and i
love this man who i'm about to introduce
i mean truly do adore
this man and getting to know him and
getting to meet him and getting to work
with him as we did at the combine years
ago and i just know what football means
to this man and i know what football has
also done for this man and his wife
carol
and their journeys together and the fact
that they are now going to journey to
the pro football hall of fame together
means so much to me
and that's the way i wanted to introduce
my friend
and pro football hall of famer dick for
meal here
on the rich eisen show how are you sir
rich needless to say we are floating
very high right now carol sitting across
from me here in the sun in key west
florida our daughter's second home and
enjoying time here and i appreciate very
much your kind remarks and and you know
the feelings are mutual
you know it just i just know again your
journey and what you do for what you've
done for the sport and for it to finally
get recognized like this i know you say
you were floating on air but i i mean
who who do you think about when the name
dick vermeel and pro football hall of
famer said in the same sentence
coach
well to be honest with you i think about
the coaches that i have great respect
and admiration for that aren't in there
yet and i'm going to try to save my seat
and i hope i live long enough to see
them all get in because as you know rich
we have some very deserving people out
there that aren't in there yet and
there's only been 10 coaches put in in
the last 25 years
so there's room for more and when people
ask me i i thank god i'm so grateful
so grateful but also uh
i'm sorry these other guys aren't
already in
well i mean who was your mentor dick
when you first started who who's that
that that person who gave you the leg up
and started to
you know
help you hone your x's and o's who's
that well rick
if it wasn't for a high school coach
taking his first head coaching job at
capistoga
and you know in 1954 i probably would
not be sitting here you know he just
inspired the hell out of me and
he was so
positive about what he thought i could
do as a football player i know i'm the
count of you know 1800 people to school
130 kids in it and he tells you you know
you could play football and i just love
the game you know and
so i decided well i'm going to be like
bill wood i'm going to go to junior
college catch up then i walked on at san
jose state and decided i wanted to be a
high school football player and from
that time on i never turned down a job
that looked like a good advancement
opportunity
and then
just in terms of uh who opened your mind
off on offense who was that guy who
opened your mind on offense oh
i worked at stanford bill walsh was on
the staff jim moore was on the staff
mike white was on the staff i was always
around
uh you know football guys real football
guys i mean i've sat around the table
with john madden when you're junior
college coaches you know these kinds of
things but you know then in the nfl it
was ted martial brother stimulated me
roman gabriel those two people my first
year in the league in 1969 howard
schnellenberger was on that staff and i
was coaching the special teams as the
very first special teams coach ever
hired but i went to all the offensive
meetings and then later on i you know
two years later i'm back there offensive
coordinator you know and then i go to
chuck and go to chuck knox and he you
talk about sophistication in the running
game and the importance of it and the
discipline of it and the fundamentals of
teaching it you know
and these kind of things and tommy pro
throw i learned so much about practice
organization and the fundamentals
approaching to to make players better
the guys that you have make each one of
them better tommy proto you know and it
was i was so fortunate to do that then i
get into you know my own jobs and then i
bring sid gilman with me you know and
sid gilman was like having a walking
encyclopedia with you every day
and he didn't he coached the
quarterbacks on the field i still ran my
own offense and those kinds of things in
those days but he coached our entire
offensive staff of how to be better
football coaches as well as improved our
scheme you know and then like you know
alexander's mike march was jim mike
marks nobody did a better job than mike
mart's first year as a coordinator than
he did for us in 1999 you know and those
kind of guys jim hennepin they were all
positive positive influences on me
really dick vermeel pro football hall of
famer here on the rich eisen show and
you know when madden went in he said the
busts talk to each other when the lights
go out at night what that great
statement i know right what what will
your bust say to maddens when the lights
go uh dick
i say john you deserve every accolade
you have received since your passing and
i hope everybody said that to you before
you pass so you really know how sincere
and meaningful you were to people in the
national football league you know he
helped me also on broadcasting i
shoveled on the bus
and that kind of stuff so and you know
he was so good to me when i came into
the league because like i said
we we met all the way back in junior
college coaching days and uh he was the
first guy that called me
when i got the head job at the
philadelphia eagles and invited me to
spend time with him at our first owners
meetings and he spent all his free time
with me you know and then i get in
broadcasting all of a sudden i'm doing
games next to his booth i'm not live he
is and
myself and frank lieber did two
broadcasts
on side boost and traveled on the bus
with him to the next game so i have you
know i have
great admiration and respect for the man
you know well i mean i i honestly when i
heard that you know sean mcvay was
potentially thinking about going into
broadcasting now at age 36 after winning
a super bowl and getting to his second
with the rams i honestly thought of
madden and i thought of you
dick about you know successful coaches
talking about burnout talking about how
difficult it is to
to keep grinding it out and that
broadcasting might be a better
way of life what what what what do you
say about that possibility that mcveigh
could be thinking about that right now
well probably i hope he doesn't
you know he's got so much to give to the
game not that he hasn't already given it
to the game
but there's so much in this guy he he's
a he's a living football and i think his
mind just sees things so brilliantly as
he evaluates what he's going to do and
how he's going to prove his scheme and
these kind of things he has so much more
to give to the game and in broadcasting
believe me it's a lot of fun and you
meet so many wonderful people and i had
such an advantage and i got to sit in
meeting rooms of many many great coaches
sit at offensive meetings quarterback
meetings team meetings talk to teams
because of the respect that i had gained
as a head football coach and then i'd go
to broadcast the game
brett and i worked together eight years
and we'd go in early and spend time with
these different coaches and i know it
was just i i i learned some things
i regained some confidence i said to
myself many times you know these guys
are doing it better than i was doing it
from time to time i'd say you know i
like how i did it better than they're
doing it you know
but i saw some great coaches the bill
schneiders at kansas state is probably
as fine a football coach as i've ever
seen coach especially a college football
team tom coughlin when he was at boston
college i got to know him real well and
what's he do he gets in the nfl and does
a really good hall of fame caliber job
you know
so uh
i just think
sean has so much to give to the game and
uh i i would be
i would be disappointed if they left the
game this early you know
and and it just it's just amazing how um
you know the rams winning a championship
hoisting the trophy and it's the first
time in los angeles they did it and you
know it brought back so many great
memories obviously of your
99 run um what what did you think of
kurt's movie dick what'd you think of
that one
you know i liked it
carol and i hosted it in three different
states where it really went public and i
and every time i saw it i liked it
better because i better unders
because i didn't have a deep insight
into his early days prior to getting to
me we brought him there in 98 you know
they left out the first year with the
rams 1998 as our third quarterback and
that's where i really got to know it and
watch him and and rich i learned if
you're not coaching your own offense or
your own defense as a head coach you see
a lot more on the practice field of all
your players and i can remember watching
him and coming off the field from time
to time and he just ate our defense
alive thinking you know
this kid can play or else our defense
thinks
[Laughter]
by the time it came to make the decision
was he going to be our starter when
trent greene went down
i had some depth because i watched him
three days a week throw against our
defense you know
you have a tendency as a coach to not go
on what you see you go on what you hear
other people say and your your opinion
would like yeah he probably can't do
that under pressures running these plays
off cards you know what would he do in
front of 80 000 people well he went
beyond everybody's expectations okay so
that's why he's in the hall of fame and
the movie the movie's beautiful as you
you pointed out about his personal life
and about you know brenda and their son
and their kids and and and
and the journey uh and and obviously the
scene you know where where dennis quaid
is playing you the we will rally around
kurt warner and we will play good
football did you like like did you have
to psych yourself up to say that you've
believed it in your bones i mean that's
such a famous speech that's now in the
movie history
dick what was that actually
i really believed it plus
as a leader
it it's important that you
transmit energy that people can believe
your team
our team was ready to be a good football
team and
i told john shaw
prior to training camp in 99 this was
going to be a very good football team
and he said coach don't tell me that a
lot of coaches have told me that before
this season said john i've been on good
teams this is a good football team i you
know and i knew
trent greene had a great feel for trent
what great job he was going to do and
then
but
the background of watching curt
for a whole season as the third
quarterback in pro
gave me confidence in my staff's
confidence to make him our number two
quarterback in the first place in 99
and
i i knew he would play well i did not
know he would play as well as he did no
quarterback you can study it any way you
want to no quarterback ever played the
first six seven games of his career
under and performed like kurt warner did
no one has ever
yeah that is the truth man there's no
question about that and now i mean look
at you dick you had you've had dennis
quaid and greg kinnear play you in
movies look at you you're like you come
hollywood it's amazing yeah you know
well my wife requested it would be what
was that guy's name bro brad pitt actors
like carol
uh excuse me it doesn't come to my mind
it's okay right
the brad pitt it's usually brad pitt
brad was brad pitt
i'd love it
oh man
all right so now let's get to finishing
up the most important questions first
how's the wine doing dick how's the wine
business well
what's going on with brandon say that in
13 years of business
we're in the black doing well we've got
over 425 club members and it's growing
our concern now is having lost all our
red grapes in the 2020 forest fire due
to smoke damage right we're going to be
sort of red wines uh yeah
in the year it's those are due to be
sold and marketed so we're going to be a
little bit behind at that time but
i think thomas brown is going to step up
and let us move some of his red into our
tasting room and and supplement club
members and that kind of stuff yeah as
if uh andy jones our winemaker so that's
gonna help us yeah well i mean your wine
is phenomenal i talk about it all the
time dick it really is is some of the
best it's of course are you kidding me
you're you're the vermeel wines and it's
just terrific it's
phenomenal yeah
well i appreciate you saying that i
believe it because we have
you know our two wine people
thomas brown and andrew
they and they do a great job and we have
i've been involved with the vineyard the
freddie anne vineyard all my life
i know that venue it's 107 acres of
railroad kalisto
ground that produces wonderful grapes
and so we have a good product and we
don't cut corners and we didn't go in
the business just to make
money because it you really can't do
that
in the wine business like we have little
tiny places but we went in to make as
best the wine as we could make and it
right now we're moving that way
vermeelwines.com everybody should go
check it out it really is spectacular
and then um have you sat for your bust
yet do you know what you what you want
you want philadelphia era do you want st
louis era what are we going to go for
here for the look on your bus well i'm
going to i'll go in as an eagle but with
great respect for the rams and the
chiefs but you know i live in
philadelphia my co-chair said i know
more of the kids i still call them kids
that i coached about 18 of them 17 of
them live right there in town and i see
them all the time and have dinner with
them share wine with them and so i think
i i would prefer to go in as an eagle
with great admiration and respect for
the rams and chiefs and brag about being
off with involved with all three of them
so but the look of the bus you'll have
the hairline of the philadelphia era
that's what you're going to have for the
bus the look yeah okay yeah i guess so i
know that they've done all the
measurements okay how great is this how
great is he doing measurement this is
the hall of fame dick it's happening and
it's so deserved and kurt's the one who
knocked on your door although kurt told
me that you
you kind of heard him coming up the
driveway and you and cal were already
out there pretty much i thought i
thought it was a ups delivery
harold knew they were coming okay okay
all right and that's how we had our two
boys there because she had our number
two son rick
david over there to help he does our
financial stuff and
supposedly we were having a family
financial meeting and she said
oh rick our older son hadn't had
breakfast with us a long time so she has
him over i'm sitting here in my old work
clothes and uh black t-shirt and
thinking i'm gonna be out working uh
cleaning some wood stuff because the
wind's
knocked everything down and
the buzzer on the driveway goes off i
get up i say oh ups here early i go out
and here's kurt warner walking through
the woods in a gold jacket
right away hey
i made
you made it and then the question is you
know dick is there's always um
uh a wager amongst the
class when they're coming in together
there's always a wager as to who's gonna
cry first
and i'm i'm guessing that you're just
going to make everybody just change that
wager that you'll just make that off the
boards pretty much right i mean
you know that's what we're going to be
talking about come august yeah well
that's me you know it used to really
bother me now you know
all you can be is yourself that's it and
i heard schwarzkopf one time make the
statement on on 60 minutes he didn't
worry about those that cried he worried
about those that didn't that made me
feel pretty good you know
you got to be yourself and i have found
myself
it tears in my eyes many times in my
career but for all the right reasons
well maybe we can get you a kleenex
sponsorship for canton something like
let's let's work it in your favor
because that's what people want to see
they want to see you be you and on
behalf of everybody dick at the network
who's come across you i always feel
confident being able to speak for all of
my colleagues
my gosh are we just so happy for you and
carol it is so well deserved
and we loved getting to know you and
work with you back in the day and we
kind of feel like you know we're going
in with you
that's a fact
i appreciate that very much and i know
you're very sincere i mean thank you you
take care of yourself dick say hi to
your wife and uh say hi to carol for me
and the rest of the family and congrats
again all right bye-bye you gotta stick
for meal everybody
it's himself he's going to be him
let's get him a gig let's get him a deal
oh it's coming they they bet all the
time who's going to crack first who's
going to go first that's that i mean
that's off the board it's off the board
he's off the board who's going to crack
second who's going to go who's going
second
is it you basely
[Laughter]
seymour
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here